♪〜
こんにちは
無駄に
はい、というわけでみなさん
もう夏ですよね
そう
特にメンズとかはこう…
やっぱ汗をかくと思うんですよね
もちろんぼくも夏は汗かくんで→
ちょっとニオイが気になったり
するんですけども〜→
そんな夏だからこそ！！
他の男たちと差をつけたいと
思いませんか///
ま　今回のターゲットは
ぼくじゃないんですけどもね。
はい。というわけでぼくの後輩に
たて面という男がいるんですけども→
この男がですね…
ちょっとあの…んー…
♪〜
ニオイがねぇ…
♪ドゴォォォォォンWWWWWWW
あの　これ以上言わないっス
察してください！！
柔らかく言うと→
多分
匂いに興味がないんですよアイツ
そこで私　ひらめいてしまいましたァ
やっぱ匂いに興味がない人…
どうすればいいかって考えたところ→
もっとこう　シンプルに手短に→
パッ　ハッ　て→
一瞬でいい匂いに
なれればいいなと思いまして→
はい　こちらにございます↗︎
↘︎なんですけども　この大量のAXEを
使って→
AXEゲートを作ります
この大量のAXEでゲート…門を作って→
すれば→
その門をくぐるだけで
一瞬で
良い匂いになる///
今回はそんな↗︎
AXEゲートを作って
ターゲットのたて面に→
素敵な良い匂いの→
男性になってもらおうと思います
ではいこう★
というわけでAXEゲートを
作るんですけども→
やるんだからもう
本格的なヤツを作りたいので→
ぼく1人だと作れないんで
業者の方に→
手伝っていただいて　作ることに
なりました
よろしくお願いしまぁぁす
(業者)お願いしまーす
結構ガチガチの本格的な
ヤツができる予定です！
多分こういうところに
AXEが置いていかれる気がします
(はじめ)ぼくにできることがあれば…
(業者)あ　ちょっと…
(はじめ)任してください
(業者)ちょっと…持ち上げてもらって
いいですか　(はじめ)はい
♪〜
はい　というわけでAXEゲートに
使っていくAXEは　こちらのですね〜↗︎
↘︎こちらの2種類を
使っていこうと思います
おぉー！
♪〜はじめんは見ているだけです♪(ごめんなさい)
♪(変調)〜
というわけで
AXEゲートの完成でーす！
[拍手]
ありがとうございます　本当に。
クオリティが高すぎてビックリ
はい　というわけで見ていきましょう
ご覧ください
ゲートの1番上には “AXE” の文字
そし…てぇ！両サイドから
大量のAXEが噴射されるので→
もうゲートの横にはAXEがしっかりと
敷き詰められております
こういう感じで全部スイッチに
なってるんですよね？
えっと　下のここが起動スイッチに
なっているので→
ターゲットが…入ってきて
ここをぎゅって踏むと
噴射されて一斉に
バァッて出る仕組みになっております//
ちょっと実際に踏んでみまーす(M)
いきますよー　踏んでみます
♪〜
ふみまーーす！！
[ｼｭｰ]
わあああ！！うぅグヘェッ　ヘッ
すごい勢いです…ｗ
ヤバい　もう匂いが！
↘︎で埋めつくされる〜
というわけでちょっと→
デコレーションをしてみたんで
だいぶ→
AXEゲート感は強くなった
かなーと思います
というわけで早速ターゲットを呼んで→
このゲートをくぐるだけで
めちゃくちゃ良い匂いの男になって→
最強にモテる男を目指してもらいたいと
思います　ではいこう！
では…
♪〜
(はじめ)たて面　AXEって知ってる？
(たて面)AXE？　(はじめ)うん
(たて面)あ〜！
(はじめ)あの良い匂いの。
(たて面)あぁ　良い匂いだと思いますよ
(はじめ)おぉ〜いいんじゃない？
(たて面)えっはじめさん使ってるんスか？
(はじめ)オレめっちゃ好きなんだよ
(たて面)あぁいいっスね
♪〜
うわ　なにこれ！
え　扉？扉？　(はじめ)じゃない
(たて面)なんスかこれ
どういう…
♪〜
(たて面)なんとなくわかったぞぉ〜
(たて面)え　通…通ればいいんスよね？
多分きっと。
はいぃ…
はい…
♪〜
え？違いますか？
ちょっと…ちょっと乗って　その上に
(たて面)はい
(はじめ)ジャンプしてみて
(たて面)あ　この線ですか？
(はじめ)そう　全体重かけて
(たて面)わかりました
[ﾄﾞﾝ　ｼｭｰｰｰ]
ぅおおおおお！！！！
すげーすげーすげー！！
[ﾄﾞﾝ　ｼｭｰｰｰ]
ぅおおおおお！！！！
すげーすげーすげー！！
ヴァーーーーーーー　スゴイ
(はじめ)はっはっはｗｗ
(はじめ)たて面　匂い嗅いでみ　匂い
(はじめ)自分の。
あ　めっちゃ良い匂いなりましたん♡
(はじめ)よぉぉ　やった！！
(たて面)ヤバい！やったぁ！え　スゴイ
アァッ　そういうことかぁ
たて面！
(たて面)はい
お前モテたいって言ってたよなぁ！
(たて面)はい！言ってました！
たて面がモテたい　そして良い匂いに
なってほしいために作った…
くぐるだけで良い匂いになれる
AXEゲートでーーーす！！
うぉぉぉ
え　うれしい！
(はじめ)ねぇ！
(たて面)え　スゴイ…
(たて面)…結構かかったっスよね
上もすごいよ見てみ
(たて面)AXEって書いてある　(はじめ)そう
(たて面)えぇ…かっこよ！
あぁすごい入ってる！しっかりこう…
(はじめ)そうなんだよそうなんだよ
スゴーイ…
わ゛ぁ゛ぃ゛ぃ゛
あぁでもこれで
良い匂いになるっスね　一瞬で。
夏は使え！AXEを。
(たて面)ありがとうございます　使います
(はじめ)ほら　良い匂いになって
虫も寄ってくるぞ〜
(たて面)スゴーイ！
虫からもモテるんスね
(はじめ)そうだ
(たて面)ヤッタァ☆
はい　というわけで今回はですね〜
このたて面という男を↗︎
↘︎にするためにAXEゲートを
作ってみました　どうでしたか？
いや　よかったです
(はじめ)や　もうね
ほんとですかぁ！？
(はじめ)ほんとに。(たて面)やったぁ！
嘘なんだけどね？
(たて面)ぇ？
これから良い男になっていきます。な？
(たて面)あ　そっすか　これから。。
や　ほんと　匂い大事ですからね？
ほんとに。はい
で　AXE　今回めっちゃ　ぼく
体につけたんですけども
でですね　AXE　色んな香りの
バリエーションがあるんで→
ちょっと見ていきましょうか
はい　こちらが今日使った
エッセンスとキロです
そしてこちら　パリをイメージした匂い
ゴールド
パリだとよ？　(たて面)おぉ！
おぉ！
はっはっはｗｗ
あぁ！パリ行ったことないけど
多分パリってこういう匂いする
(たて面)ぇ？
上海をイメージしたスウィート。
甘い匂い好きなんだよね　結構
わぁーーー！！！
めっちゃ甘い！　(たて面)あ　これ好き！
(はじめ)フルーティーですね
そしてこちらがブラック。
ニューヨークをイメージした匂いです
これがニューヨークの匂いだぞ
(たて面)はい
あ〜〜〜！！
すごい
かっこいい匂いがするなぁ
そしてこちら　シドニーをイメージした
クリックという匂いです
あーーいいなぁ　爽やか！
え　スウィート…めっちゃイイっす…
というわけでAXEいろんな種類が
あるので　ぜひみなさん→
自分が好きな匂い…のAXEを
使ってみてください！
そしてですね　なんとキャンペーンの
お知らせがございます！
↘︎してくださった
フッ…ｗｗ
そして！キャンペーン用のツイートを
リツイートしてくださった方の中から↗︎
AXE限定のはじめしゃちょーのチェキを
プレゼントいたします！
[拍手]
欲しいな　(たて面)欲しぃ〜
やらんぞ？　(たて面)ぃい？
詳しい内容は動画の概要欄にあります！
ぜひ！みなさん　そちらをチェック
してください！
AXEを使って素敵な匂いで→
夏を過ごしてみてください☆
じゃあな！
[通常ED]炎上するんじゃないで(メッセ)
ほんと使いな？
(たて面)はい　ほんとに
な。あなた良い匂いしたら
良いよ　ほんとに。
ほんとですか？　(はじめ)うん
ヤッタァ！
ちゃんと使うんだぞ？
(たて面)ちゃんと使います